I've tried to make my home feel like my
sanctuary
[Music]
only et got an inside look at southern
charm star Katherine Dennis's new
three-story three bed three and a half
bath Charleston home well I am renting
this house month-to-month but it does
give off the feeling that I've earned a
space of my own I'm not living under
someone else's rules
aka decorating and it makes me feel
really proud I've worked really hard to
get where I am and you know I see them
happy in this space and it makes me I
don't know I just feel complete this
sounds cliche but they would be
Katherine's of two kids Kenzie and Saint
whom she shares with ex Thomas Ravenel
there's lots of space for the children
to do whatever they want we build forts
and this is my new white couch that they
have yet to it's so white I know as far
as we can tell the kiddos have kept
their destruction at bay Saints got his
own of baby mancave downstairs while
upstairs you'll find a Kenzie's room and
Katherine's master suite do you feel
very adult in this house I do in the
sense that there's a lot less stuff so
I'm able to like be calm and like in the
moment at all times because I don't have
something I need to clean or someone you
could does that make sense
you saw my house and like my closet last
time like yes so many things just well I
want to see what your closet looks like
now everybody go in there new and
improved closet I've cut down about 70%
okay it's still bright colorful yeah of
course it's like my brain just like
throw up everywhere oh the last time I
was in your closet you saw it all the
stuff that Thomas had given you over the
years yeah it's gone it's gone yeah not
that out of your life yeah I purged and
I mean I got rid of place 70% of things
and his was all included I just don't
want that in my life now you know I'm in
a new place and I just
it's not needed get given your jewelry
and stuff that's not mmm okay new energy
in here right exactly
it's actually like made me a lot happier
you live kind of a crazy life there's a
lot that goes on in your life how do you
find the strength to maintain your
sobriety in the chaos of your life um
well I will say that I stay out of a lot
of the things I used to do obviously
which is the social events the silly
like parties and whatnot and I spend a
lot of time at home and really I'm so
like not at all the craziness outside of
me that I live in the perfect little
bubble I can't ever really put my finger
on exactly how but I guess easiest way
to describe it is like my children every
time I look at them and if I'm not with
them are just go to photos on my phone
it's not weird that's what moms do right
I could talk in circles about it but
really it's my children yeah number one
priority
absolutely absolutely if he doesn't tell
obviously mommy it's just overwhelming
like the court gates good news this
season there's gonna be new tough
obstacles that you probably did not see
coming with Thomas now how did you
handle that and what's gonna be the
tough part of watching it back the tough
part of watching it back is that when it
did happen it was such an emotional
roller coaster that I feel like my brain
could not handle it's gonna be a lot of
reminders are just those feelings I went
through I didn't know how to feel I mean
it's not an everyday situation right but
it is what it is and I've learned to
accept that way of thinking and all
aspects of my life I suppose but yeah
it's very different this year is it
better worse or really it's better in
the sense that I'm just living my life
I'm not a product of a relationship I'm
not someone's girlfriend I'm not dealing
with anyone else
is life per se and I'm able to just live
my own like show people the real me at
the very root of it you know return to
my roots and that in and of itself feels
liberating and makes me really proud so
I'm not perfect by any means I might
still get a little krump but I'm
definitely grew up a lot
[Music]
[Applause]